foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing a segment from a Deathly
Hallows involving Draco Malfoy and Harry
Potter more specifically we'll be
addressing the moment that Draco Malfoy
fails to identify Harry Potter in the
presence of his father and fellow Death
Eaters what I want to explore is why did
Draco simply fail to recognize Harry was
it an act of self-preservation or was
this draco's chance at some form of
redemption let's dive in but before we
get started I want to let you in on
something I've become a Lord and so can
you today's video is sponsored by
established titles established titles is
a fun and novel way to preserve the
natural Woodlands of Scotland while
helping Global reforestation efforts
it's a Project based on a historic
Scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as leads or Lords and Ladies
in English that means you could become a
lord just like me but here's the best
part do you know where Hogwarts is
Scotland and do you know where our
established titles gives you land or
Scotland Hogwarts may have a concealment
charm hiding its exact location but this
is your opportunity to potentially state
claim to land near Hogwarts title packs
give you at least one square foot of
dedicated land with a unique plot number
on a private estate in edelton Scotland
and an official certificate with the
crest with this certificate you could
potentially include the title Lord or
lady on things like credit cards plane
tickets and even dating profiles it
makes an amazing last minute gift and
established titles is actually running a
massive Black Friday sale right now
views the code HP Theory at checkout you
get an additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com HP Theory to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel the first 200 people purchasing
a title pack using my link will
effectively be next to my plot within
just a few minutes of walking distance
depending on how many of you want to
become a lord or lady we can build our
little Harry Potter Theory Kingdom I
should also mention that established
titles plant a tree with every order and
they work with global charity one tree
planted and trees for the future to
support Global reforestation efforts
back to the video it all begins on
chapter 23 of the Deathly Hallows Malfoy
Manor where there is some confusion
around Harry's identity now let's see
who we've got said grayback's gloating
voice from overhead and Harry was rolled
over onto his back a beam of wand light
fell onto his face and greyback laughed
I'll be needing butterbeer to wash this
one down what happened to you ugly Harry
did not answer immediately I said
repeated greyback and Harry received a
blow to the diaphragm that made him
double over in pain what happened to you
stung Harry muttered been stung yeah
looks like it said a second voice what's
your name snarled Grayback Dudley said
Harry and your first name a Vernon
Vernon Dudley and why was Harry so
unrecognizable well just before being
captured by the snatchers Hermione smart
as always was able to fire a stinging
Jinx directly into Harry's face the
resulting swelling disfigured his face
so much that he was no longer
recognizable however despite Hermione's
quick thinking in her attempt to make
Harry unrecognizable there were still
things that allowed Harry to be easily
identified like his scar and signature
glasses what's that on your forehead
Vernon he asked softly his breath foul
in Harry's nostrils as he pressed a
filthy finger to the taut scar don't
touch it Harry held he could not stop
himself he thought he might be sick from
the pain of it I thought you wore
glasses Potter breathed Grayback I found
glasses we helped one of the snatchers
skulking in the background there was
glasses in the tent gray back wait and
seconds later Harry's glasses had been
rammed back onto his face the snatchers
were closing in now peering at him it is
rasped greybank we've caught Potter but
while the snatchers were entirely
confident in identifying Harry
ultimately the decision to identify
Harry in advance of alerting the dark
lord fell on Draco as he knew him best
they say they've got Potter said nazis's
cold voice Draco come here well Draco
said Lucius Malfoy he sounded Avid is it
is it Harry Potter I can't I can't be
sure said Draco he was keeping his
distance from greybank and seemed as
scared of looking at Harry as Harry was
of looking at him but look at him
carefully look come closer Harry had
never heard Lucy's Malfoy so excited
there's something there he whispered it
could be the scar stretched tight Draco
come here look properly what do you
think Harry saw drika's face up close
now right beside his fathers they were
explored ordinarily alike except that
while his father looked beside himself
with excitement draco's expression was
full of reluctance even fear I don't
know he said and he walked away towards
the fireplace where his mother stood
watching In This Moment Draco could have
changed the fate of The Wizarding World
entirely he could have redeemed his
family name brought honor at least in
the eyes of Voldemort back to his father
become a star among the Death Eaters and
secured Voldemort's rise to power what
led to his inaction I've got a few
different answers for why this happened
the first possibility that I want to
explore is in my view the least likely
that draco's inaction was solely the
result of his own desire for
self-preservation as unlikely as it is
there's always the possibility that
Draco was simply not 100 sure that this
disfigured swollen boy was Harry
in this instance draco's inability to
identify Harry would have stemmed from
his fear of misidentifying Harry if
Draco did indeed confirm that this
figure was Harry and then Voldemort was
called only to find out that this was
not Harry after all then things would
have only gotten worse for him and his
family in the books even Harry admits
that he wouldn't have recognized himself
Harry was facing a mirror over the
fireplace a great gilded thing in an
intricately scrawled frame through the
slits of his eyes he saw his own
reflection for the first time since
leaving grimald plays his face was huge
shiny in pink every feature distorted by
Hermione's Jinx his black hair reached
his shoulders and there was a dark
shadow around his jaw had he not known
that it was he who stood there he would
have wondered who was wearing his
glasses he resolved not to speak for his
voice was sure to give him away yet he
still avoided eye contact with Draco as
the latter approached but do I think
this was what led to draco's inaction
probably not the next possibility I want
to discuss is the Draco despite being a
subscriber to the ideologies of the
Death Eaters simply didn't want to put
his childhood acquaintances In Harm's
Way Draco knew that if he turned over
Harry it would have meant the end for
Harry Ron and Hermione though Draco
loathed these three or at least his
previous actions would lead us to
believe he did he didn't want to be the
cause of their deaths did he want glory
for his family yes did he want death he
to rule maybe but he didn't want any of
this at the cost of his old classmates
lives the next and most likely
possibility that I want to discuss is
that Draco no longer subscribed to the
ideologies of the Death Eaters at all he
may have always took the talk but wasn't
willing to walk the walk the events of
the Half-Blood Prince dick in their toll
on Draco and the perpetually sneering
boy that had always exuded some sort of
false confidence had started to become a
nervous wreck after being tasked with
killing his school Headmaster while we
began to witness his downfall after
being given his Dubious Task near the
beginning it wasn't until the end of the
book and Dumbledore's death that we saw
Draco reduced to someone so unlike his
former self seeing death Dumbledore
being struck down Atop The astronomy
Tower and charity Burbage being tortured
and killed in his own home
had forced Draco to recognize his own
ignorance we also have to remember that
it was Draco who set those Wheels in
Motion by allowing Death Eaters to
infiltrate Hogwarts via the vanishing
cabinet it's likely that Draco took
responsibility for Dumbledore's death
hated the feeling and wanted to avoid
having any more blood on his hands Draco
who uttered horrible slurs for basically
his entire childhood was simply echoing
the voice of his father Draco didn't
really hate muggleborns or blood
traitors he was just ignorant and too
young and unwise to recognize otherwise
after witnessing death for the first
time Draco recognized that there was a
distinct difference between snaring
insults and condemning his old
classmates to a long painful and
publicized death
expanding on this it's possible that
Draco simply began to imagine what a
future under Voldemort's rule might look
like just a few years prior Draco didn't
have a care in the world but now he was
torturing Death Eaters for Voldemort
watching his professors get murdered and
watching his father who he so looked up
to get belittled and marginalized by the
man who was meant to be the new ruler of
the Wizarding World it wasn't a game
anymore and the dark mark on his arm
reminded him of every moment he spent
awake in the nightmare that his life had
become identifying Harry would have
eliminated the one chance he had of Life
returning to normal Another Thing Worth
looking at is that Draco said I don't
know not no what does this mean in my
opinion Draco failing to outright deny
that the this unidentified figure was
Harry was never representative of him
wishing harm upon his old schoolmate his
indecision was simply the product of his
mind Wang the path that he had taken
with the path that he now needed to take
despite recognizing what cause of action
he would now need to take he couldn't
quite vocalize his commitment to it and
that's why he ended up settling for a
passive I don't know the last question
that needs to be answered on this topic
is why on Earth draco's father Lucius
wasn't able to recognize Harry Lucius
admit Harry on multiple occasions and he
knew who Harry hung out with in the
Chamber of Secrets he mentions to
Hermione that Draco told him all about
her and even points out Ron's red hair
and it's not like Harry's iconic scar
was some big secrets Lucia's comments on
Harry scar earlier in the series forgive
me your sky guys Legend what's the deal
here here's the thing he probably did
but without absolute certainty calling
Voldemort would have been a very poor
decision especially if it turned out not
to be Harry Lucius was already in
Voldemort's banned books and wasting his
time further would have been very very
bad for him and his family they needed
confirmation that it was Harry without
any shred of doubt and Draco would have
been the only one to provide that
however as we know that's not quite how
things panned out and that's it for this
video did you ever Ponder draco's
indecision In This Moment did I hit the
nail on the head here or is there
something I've missed leave a comment
down below also if you enjoyed the
content it helps me a lot if you like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]